Hey guys,
Today I want to share
with you 10 things that I do every day to have
a purpose driven, fulfilled and peaceful life.
A victorious life.
And let me kick it off by giving you this quote
that I believe every man should know and live by.
CS Lewis said: "It is not your business to
succeed but to do right when you have
done so. The rest lies with God."
This is the way I live my life.
I do the right thing no matter what other
people say or even when no one is looking.
I do the right thing and then I can be
happy - content - with whatever happens
because I know I've done the right thing.
I've done my best and the rest is up to God.
Whatever happens will happen.
I can't change that.
But I have peace in my soul
and I can sleep good at night.
Now, let's start with the first thing that you
need to do every day to live a victorious life.
Make your bed and clean your room.
And let me say it as it is - have enough
respect for yourself to not live like a pig.
If your room - house for that matter - are
cluttered and things are just lying
around everywhere, then it says a lot
about the way you choose to live your life.
And it shows in your relationships - your
work - and in everything you do.
Living this way shows you are lazy,
disorganized and that you do not take
responsibility for your own mess and you
cannot even do the first task of the day.
So how are you going to do the rest
successfully if you cannot even trust
yourself with the little things.
What's going to happen with the big things?
This should be your first task of the day and
when you have done it, the rest will all fall into
place, because you will have the right mindset.
Workout.
Workout is not so much for me about improving
my body and looking good for my wife - of course
that helps - but that's not the main reason.
It's actually about improving my whole life -
my health - self-discipline - and mental health.
Working out increases your adrenaline and energy
that goes to the brain and improves memory,
and over a period of time, working out
consistently helps with the creation
of new brain cells in the hippocampus.
I bet a lot of you didn't know that huh.
And apart from that it also - man - it prevents
so many health risks and prevention is always
better than just waiting for it and then getting
sick, or getting a health problem that you will
struggle with for the rest of your life.
It reduces the risk of high cholesterol,
high blood pressure, inflammation,
diabetes, cancer, and so much more.
Guys, you need to be healthy
in mind, body, and spirit.
So you got to take care of your body.
If you don't, what do you think is
going to happen?
You only have one
body - you're not going to get another one -
and then for a lot of men, regret comes too
late when you're stuck with health problems.
We're not meant to just sit in front of the
computer the whole day and just work.
You're meant to be active.
So go out there - work out - enjoy
life - and be at 100% all the time.
Three.
Good grooming.
I've said this before on this channel.
It is wrong to be vain, right?
And you get your self-confidence and
everything else from the way you look.
That is wrong because that comes from God.
But you need to have enough respect for yourself
- made in the image of God - that you take care of
your body, the only body that God gave you, which
if you are a reborn Christian, is a temple of God.
So be thankful to God and take care of yourself.
Look tidy, neat, professional
and approachable to all people.
If you don't groom yourself, you will look
lazy, unprofessional and unapproachable.
This is what I do in a nutshell to get ready
for the day - a quick shower, I will add all
the grooming products I believe in and use
personally for you in the video description
down below.
Geology for my
hair care and skincare is the most important.
It works because it's personalized skincare.
They send it to me each month.
That works for my unique skin - which helps my
dry skin - dark circles under my eyes - blackheads
- prevent pimples - and gives me clear skin.
Next I do a quick beard trim if needed.
Then I shave the hair on my cheeks,
neck and sides.
Next is sea salt spray.
I use it to dry my hair into the
style I want and finish it with
American Crew pomade and maybe a
touch of hairspray if necessary.
That's it.
Grooming done.
Always look professional, neat and approachable.
Now again, I'll add all the details for in the
video description down below and
also a discount code for Geology.
Read the Bible and pray with coffee.
This is the most important time of the day for me.
This is where I get my energy from.
This is where I get my purpose - my
peace - my joy - my everything I need.
This is where I get it from,
to be able to stand strong against all
the storms that this life can bring.
It doesn't matter because I'm rooted
in Christ and He gives me what I need.
If I start my day with God - then nothing
of this temporary world can get me down,
because I live by a real faith and
not by sight, which helps me to see
what normal people can't, enabling me to act
in God confidence and not self-confidence.
Eat healthy but tasty food.
This is so important.
One of the most important things because a lot of
people think that when they start to eat healthy,
that it's not going to be tasty.
It's so wrong.
You just need to find the healthy
food that's tasty for you.
This is extremely important for me - to live
a consistently healthy life, that will help
me to always be at 100%.
To always be healthy.
So for breakfast I love to eat oats with
mixed nuts- berries - and whey protein.
For lunch and dinner, I choose any healthy
meat and preferably green vegetables.
I also love eggs, whether it's
scrambled, poached or omelets - it
is so important to live a healthy balanced life.
And a lot of people complain because they're so
tired and sometimes they feel depressed and a lot
of it has got to do with the food that you eat.
So you just improve that and it improves the rest.
But it is important to eat the things you love,
so try different healthy food and then just stick
to the healthy food that you actually love to eat.
Schedule your priorities.
If you have a lot of things to do,
it is important to focus on the things
that's the most important and do that.
For me, running two ministries - DLM Men's
Lifestyle - the Christian Lifestyle - now
also starting Ruach Entertainment - there
are always certain things that I will need
to sacrifice because I don't have enough
time to do everything I really want to do.
So I need to look at the things that are the
most important for that day, and then do it.
So DLM Christian Lifestyle and also Men's
Lifestyle, with all its video editing, thumbnails,
social media, marketing emails, team management -
all the meetings - everything takes a lot of time.
Then we're also starting up Ruach
Entertainment which of course I
can't talk about yet but it takes a lot of time.
So I will literally sit down and ask myself this
important question - what are the most important
things that I need to take care of today?
And I write them down.
Some of the things I can
remember but if I'm a little bit afraid that I
might not remember certain things I write it down.
If you want to reach your big goals
you need to reach all the small
goals that will take you to the big goal.
You need structure in your daily routine
to achieve those daily goals that will
help you to get closer to the big goals.
If you only dream about it and do nothing
- not having a plan - you are planning to
fail and those dreams will just stay dreams.
Everyone just gets 24 hours in a day and those
who achieve their goals with hard work are just
those who use 24 hours better than other people.
Do what needs to be done even
if you don't feel like it.
Man, this is something my
mother burned into my brain.
Even today, I can just hear her voice right now.
We all have to do certain things that we don't
like at certain times to get closer to the
things we really want most out of life.
And this is true even with
the little things in life.
For example, you might not like taking 30
minutes to prepare a tasty meal, but once
you eat it it is all worth it and then another
example is you might not like working out, right?
But what you really want is a
good, fit body to be healthy.
And if you don't have one, you have to do workouts
- you have to eat healthy - which you might not
like in the beginning - but as you start to
see the results with consistency - 1 month,
2 months, 3 months - and you see the
changes - then you start liking it.
And then you endure it - you go to the gym - you
do what needs to to be done to reach your goal.
The things that you really care about, that are
worth it to pursue, often require hard work.
And doing things that you don't like - that's
temporary to get you to the thing you really
want - that you want most in life.
So stop complaining.
Pull up your socks and do what must
be done even if you don't like it.
No excuses.
Make coffee for someone.
I'm actually serious.
If you live a life where you're
at work for example and you just
always make coffee for yourself, that's
a selfish life which is an unhappy life.
The little things matter.
Coffee is just an example.
You see, living life in such a way where you
care about other people and do small things
for them like making a quick coffee
which takes so little time might be
the greatest thing they experience that day.
Then suddenly the next day you go and they ask
if you want coffee and then you start to realize
oh wait a minute, my actions create reactions from
other people and that improves your social life.
You start to enjoy your relationships
with other people.
People start to care about you,
because they feel that you care about them.
And suddenly you have an amazing social life.
One of the worst things in this world is to be
alone, even when there are people around you.
Find the moment to smell the flowers.
A lot of guys out there focus so much
on the daily grind that they kind of
lose themselves in their work.
They burn themselves out and
they forget to enjoy life.
For some reason they start
to falsely believe that they will only start
to enjoy life once they reach their goals.
They want to chase their dreams so hard because
they think that that's the only thing that's going
to make them happy.
That's wrong.
They forget that the journey is actually more
important than the dream, because once they
reach it - the top of the mountain - they
realize that it was all about the journey.
Because now they need another dream again.
They lost their purpose.
So stop and smell the flowers on your journey.
Make time to enjoy life and don't
wait until you reach your goals or
retire because you don't even know
if you're going to live that long.
You can die tomorrow.
Look for the flowers every day.
Look for that special moment every day and when
you find it, stop the time and take it all in.
Don't just live to exist, but
exist to live life and enjoy life.
Appreciate everything that God has given you.
Remember John 10:10 says:
[John 10:10]
The last one - Number 10
- thank God for every day.
I mean it.
Appreciate every day that you have been given.
Because life is a gift.
Your life.
Just the fact that you can listen to this
video - that you can breathe - that you
can watch - that you can hear - it is a gift.
In the morning when I pray to God, I make it a
habit to first thank Him for another day,
To appreciate it.
You know, most people can have a better life
instantly by just changing your outlook on life.
You choose how you want to look at life and how
you react to everything you experience in life.
A lot of people are negative, pessimistic
unnecessarily living that way.
They're allowing the devil to
come in and steal their joy.
Don't let him steal your joy but look to Christ.
Look to truth.
Look at the light.
Live in the light not in the darkness.
If you do that, you will start to understand that
you cannot find peace, joy, everything you need.
That fulfillment - you cannot find it
from temporary things.
You find it only from God
Himself that guards your heart - and your
mind - with peace that you cannot explain.
That surpasses all understanding.
Because you live in that relationship with Him.
You can choose to live this way.
A good example is Psalm 118: 24.
[Psalm 118:24]
I choose to live my life in the
truth according to God's Word.
And let me tell you, life is good
even in trials and tribulations.
It surpasses even my understanding how I can have
peace in even the most difficult times in my life.
Now, go out there and live life in God
confidence, not in self-confidence.
And if you don't know what that
means, what is God confidence,
then please watch this video
here, and I'll see you there.
And always remember,
Life is short.
So don't waste yours.
Cheers guys.